il ferait bon vivre dans les yvelines le
département compte 2001 habitants
supplémentaires selon les chiffres
entrer en vigueur au 1er janvier 2013
d'après l'insee les yvelinois sont au
nombre de 1 million quatre cent trente
5448 habitants soit une augmentation de
0 13% en un an
c'est trappe qui enregistre la plus
forte augmentation avec 760 habitants
supplémentaires soit une hausse de 2 56%
la ville compte désormais 29 1705
habitants son maire guy malandain met en
avant la bonne desserte de la commune
son dynamisme économique et son offre de
logements manille connaît également une
légère augmentation
a contrario les autres villes de
l'agglomération connaissent un recul
voisins le bretonneux enregistre une
baisse de 1,43 pour cent de sa
population et compte désormais douze
mille 122 habitants de même à montigny
où le nombre d'habitants a chuté de 1,13
pour cent pour atteindre 33 1899 au 1er
janvier
idem pour l encours guyancourt et la
verrière versailles demeure la plus
grande ville du département avec 88 1253
habitants la plus petite commune des
yvelines reste sans surprise le tartre
godrans avec 31 habitants
cependant l'insee considère qu'un
comparatif sur cinq ans est nécessaire
pour apprécier la variation de la
population au sein d'une commune